io vi parlerò e vi porterò in un
incontro
questo è il mio nonno lui ammazzava i
suoi conigli le sue galline e alla fine
di questo meraviglioso rituale prendeva
i suoi conigli e le sue galline e di
appoggiava a terra su un giornale
poi mi chiamava come assistente iniziava
a sezionarli con una meticolosità
chirurgica e a togliere visceri organi
da questi conigli da queste galline mi
dimostrava e li mostrava con una
pazienza infinita tutte le loro
connessioni mia nonna invece quando
eravamo ammalati prendeva la sua pentola
rigorosamente di alluminio pentola di
alluminio ci metteva la brace della
stufa cospargeva di zucchero e via con
grandi gesti circolari se ne andava per
tutta la casa inondandola di un profumo
misto tra il bruciato e il caramello e
recitava delle frasi per me
incomprensibili magiche con l'intento di
allontanare i malanni dalla casa
io questo incontro me lo porto dentro
ancora adesso e credo di aver mutuato
dal mio nonno la passione per l'anatomia
e per la medicina basata sull'evidenza e
dalla mia nonna la passione per il
potere della parola taumaturgico già di
per se stesso curativo dopo questo
incontro
io credo chelsea anche se un po di
battuta
tra filosofia e medicina di fare il
medico quindi intrapreso un percorso
tradizionale
ho iniziato la facoltà di medicina poi
la specialità in oncologia medica e poi
prima della specialità ho avuto la
fortuna di fare un altro incontro quello
con una dottoressa che era partita con
come anestesista d'assalto anestesista
pediatrica a seguire aveva iniziato a
fare oncologia e poi cure palliative e
questo incontro ha aperto una porta
nella mia vita
lei accompagnava ai pazienti alla fine
con il suo esserci lei c'era era in
silenzio ma un silenzio premio un
silenzio carico di significato e se ne
stava lì ad aspettare quell ultimo
saluto
e così decisi anch'io di iniziare il
cammino nelle cure palliative e terapia
del dolore che ho poi continuato per 12
anni
in questi anni
poi è successo qualcosa nella mia vita
che ha riguardato la salute della mia
famiglia più cara e così ho avuto
l'opportunità di incontrare trasformando
questo dolore in un qualcos'altro una
un'altra dottoressa molto speciale che
io soprannominato l'anti qua
lei 75enne mescolava con una sapienza
mai vista per me i conigli del mio nonno
con la brace lo zucchero della mia nonna
quindi due sapere i medici che aveva
saputo così bene integrare la medicina
occidentale e la medicina cinese
e così approdai probabilmente proprio
cosi fini
a fare ad intraprendere questo percorso
di di studio di di conoscenza di
incontro con la medicina cinese e con
l'agopuntura durante le assistenze
soprattutto al domicilio dei malati
le parole che più frequentemente mi
rimbalzavano nella testa quelle che più
frequentemente ho sentito erano un vuoto
e assenza è venuto al mondo e se ne sta
già andando questo vuoto è un vuoto che
il paziente si ricava come facendo se lo
attorno già dai mesi precedenti
come a volersi proteggere e proteggere
la propria famiglia da quella che sarà
una separazione dolorosissima ed è una
ritirata
quindi una ritirata dello spirito di
protezione ed è una ritirata del corpo
che per ovvi limiti imposti dalla
malattia si spegne piano piano ma questo
è un vuoto è palpabile nelle case delle
persone che ci stanno lasciando è
palpabile nei loro familiari che
materializzano questo vuoto lo sentono
ancora prima che diventi materiale
ancora prima che la persona se ne vada
e questo vuoto e difficile da vivere
anche per noi che accompagniamo quindi
ho chiesto a questo nuovo incontro della
medicina cinese di venirmi in aiuto e
questa è la frase che ho trovato è che
mi sembra esemplificare così bene questa
visione del mondo della vita della morte
della medicina cinese che nasce dalla
filosofia taoista uscire alla vita
rientrare nella morte dove uscire
e nascere e rientrare e morire dove
uscire significa prendere una forma
quella umana rientrare significa
perderla
ma da dove entriamo e usciamo da un
grande tutto secondo l'antica sapienza
cinese da un grande tutto che ci vede in
doti potenza possiamo diventare
qualsiasi cosa in questo tutto poi
rientriamo quindi il prima e il dopo
sono uguali senza forma
io me la sono un po immaginata così
graficamente questa la nostra visione
della nostra della vita su una linea del
tempo uno spazio molto ampio che è la
nostra vita è questa quella della
medicina cinese un tutto prima un tutto
dopo è una piccola parentesi che è la
nostra vita è qui l'ideogramma della
vita in cinese
l'ho messo perché questo ideogramma
molto spesso è legato a un altro
ideogramma che è quello del cuore
i due concetti si legano e allora
andiamo al cuore di questo incontro
eccolo sentitelo
[Musica]
io ricordo ancora con emozione il
momento in cui mi hanno regalato il
primo finendo e ho ascoltato il primo
cuore davvero un suono magico ed ecco
quindi il cuore che ci ha fatto scoprire
la nostra medicina occidentale un cuore
muscolo un cuore che sistema di
conduzione un cuore che pompa sangue che
ha circolazione un cuore che evita
quanto è importante quel battito per le
persone che stanno accompagnando
qualcuno quanto è importante per i
familiari chiedere una parte ancora il
cuore c'è ancora svegliamo possiamo a
svegliarlo e ancora un cuore così ben
organizzato strutturato diviso in due
camere che non possono assolutamente
comunicare tra loro se non tra l'alto e
il basso tra il sopra e il sotto ma le
due camere rigidamente appunto divise
separate e andiamo all'altra finestra
andiamo all'altro incontro
eccolo sulla destra il meridiano del
cuore per la medicina cinese dalla mano
al braccio al cuore
questo il percorso che si superficialità
il percorso esterno che noi possiamo
pungere e trattare ma poi un
misteriosissimo percorso interno che
collega il cuore con l'intestino tenue
con il piccolo intestino ma a sinistra
meraviglioso sopra il nostro di agra
sopra il nostro disegno stilizzato del
cuore che ha un cuore chiuso
l'ideogramma del cuore per la medicina
cinese sembra mancare qualcosa per noi
manca il tetto perché il cuore sopra
deve essere aperto per poter comunicare
con gli spiriti del cielo e allora un
cuore che sembra pazza recipiente
che facilmente si riempie ma molto più
facilmente si svuota si svolta per
lasciare spazio laddove nella medicina
cinese il cuore è un organo pensante
siamo noi e la nostra identità
costitutiva e il nostro essere proprio
noi e il nostro pensiero superiore e
quindi deve essere un pensiero chiaro
limpido pulito non troppo intralciato
con un moto come quello del sangue che
non deve essere troppo turbolento
altrimenti il cuore si scompensa e
l'arte del cuore e proprio l'arte del
fare il vuoto del cuore arte che viene
chiesta in particolare al medico sapersi
riempire ma anche svuotare per
accogliere un altro pieno un'altra
parola un altra sofferenza
un'arte dell'ascoltare ma da dove
arrivano queste medicine
queste le immagini che ritraggono la
nascita della nostra medicina
nata nel 1600 con uno sguardo che forse
voleva anche lui fare il vuoto fare il
vuoto rispetto a certo oscurantismo dei
secoli precedenti avere la chiarezza il
metodo scientifico poter ripetere
esattamente un esperimento che io faccio
qui
dall'altra parte del mondo conosciuto
una tensione verso l'onestà
intellettuale verso la conoscenza che
deve entrare quindi era un guardare
all'interno sul tavolo autoptico
quindi una medicina fortemente
chirurgica fortemente anatomica nella
sua potenzialità e poi una medicina che
nel corso del tempo è stata in grado di
progettare macchine sempre più
sofisticate per guardare dentro fino
all'infinitamente piccolo a quella
nostra struttura che è forse anche la
la struttura sociale della cellula con
tutto quello che siamo in grado adesso
di codificare di questa meraviglia e qui
la base la base del pensiero cinese del
pensiero medico cinese al centro un
simbolo che tutti conoscete il tau che è
strada che via che direzione con due
forze il bianco e nero che sono anche
però la luce e il buio il giorno la
notte il maschile e il femminile lo yen
e lo yang così indissolubilmente legate
tra di loro
qui fino un equilibrio che è
trasformazione costante dell'una
nell'altra che è equilibrio
laddove l'alterazione di questo
equilibrio è la malattia
laddove la separazione è la morte e
attorno gli elementi i movimenti
anzi che costituiscono tutto l'universo
con un preciso ordine che è fisico
emotivo cosmico ci sta tutto dentro a
questi movimenti è l'uno si trasforma
nell'altro facciamo un esempio l'acqua
l'acqua ci ricorda il freddo il freddo
l'inverno l'acqua all'acqua perché
nell'inverno appartiene il nord come
organi appartengono i reni e la vescica
che sono le vie dell'acqua come è stato
di coscienza il sonno ma il sonno
profondo quello dell'inverno dove la
natura dorme come sentimento quello
della circospezione mista a paura e dove
l'acqua si congela diventa ghiaccio la
paura se è eccessiva diventa panico e ci
ferma
noi non ci muoviamo più come l'acqua che
non scorre
e quindi ecco le trasformazioni che ci
comunemente vediamo nasce un neonato poi
muore per far nascere un bambino che
muore per far nascere un adolescente e
via un adulto un anziano e così la
natura che si trasforma dall'inverno la
primavera dalla primavera l'estate
l'autunno e poi di nuovo l'inverno
concludo con questa diapositiva che non
vi deve atterrire che è tratta dalla mia
tesi di specialità in oncologia
abbiamo osservato un gruppo di pazienti
ospedalizzati sottoposti a sedazione
palliativa che è una pratica medica che
si utilizza per ridurre lo stato di
coscienza della persona malata
là dove l'aspettativa di vita sia attesa
nel giro di poche ore o giorni ma
soprattutto dove ci siano dei sintomi
non controllabili dalle comuni terapie e
dei sintomi che causano un di stress
fisico e psichico al paziente
normalmente noi osserviamo questa
sedazione con delle scale cliniche che
misurano quanto un paziente sia più
tranquillo e quanto riesca a rispondere
o meno agli stimoli e queste scale
cliniche sono quelle che vedete in verde
la linea continua e la linea
tratteggiata noi vedevamo un malato
sedato quindi non responsivo nessuno
stimolo dorme sta dormendo non stava
soffrendo dicevamo sotto a questo mare
calmo
vedete molte onde molte oscillazioni
cosa sono
abbiamo provato a mettere sulla fronte
del paziente uno strumento molto
discreto che si chiama bis che viene
comunemente utilizzato in anestesia
in sala operatoria per monitorare
appunto il grado di sedazione durante la
chirurgia del paziente
ebbene questo strumento che accoppia una
registrazione elettroencefalografica e
una registrazione elettromiografico cioè
movimenti muscolari impercettibili degli
angoli degli occhi ha mostrato questo
ogni qualvolta un familiare entrava
nella stanza del paziente ogni qualvolta
gli sussurra nell'orecchio oppure
entrava un operatore fidelizzato c'erano
degli spike delle onde cosa vuol dire
questo non sappiamo abbastanza ma una
trasformazione ovvero questa persona non
era ancora morta ma non si poteva dire
così viva eppure una continua oscillante
trasformazione di qualcosa un brulicare
un brulicare sotto ed è con questo
messaggio che vi vorrei lasciare con
questo messaggio che è integrazione con
questo messaggio che incontrò un mare
calmo e un trasformarsi la vita che poi
si trasforma nella morte con questo
ponte grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]